me l'avete che su tutti da una vita mi
stai chiedendo di fare un torneo che
questo giocattolo dauri bis oggi a
partecipare con noi faremo intorno al 33
e ci saranno colpi di scena incredibili
perché non vi ho per niente spoilerato
dal titolo che intorno al abbiamo vinto
ma vabbè per forza buona visiva le
ragazze a che figata
i favini va bene quindi socio ho scelto
io let's go my brothers buona fortuna a
tutti
l'album titoli a sinistra cosa vuol dire
tempo massimo 11 minuti cioè 11 minuti
finisce per forza si va bene ok ragazzi
ok e se finisce che siamo pari che chi
ha fatto più questa è una stronzata che
ha fatto più tiri vince chi ha fatto più
tiri che per me grandissima stronzata
perché tra l'altro ma dall altro poi
citare il coso vincitore tornino
champions e si ok quello che c'era la
gente che non ho mai capito
ok dall'altro lato possono andare io a
me la sto già pronto da tutto merito mio
questo corning anzi se non ci fossi io
che riarmi proprio guarda non ci sarebbe
partita ufficialmente la sinistra subito
aveva detto no fare sistema per loro e
sinistra spero e penso cosi
eccolo della torta che noi abbiamo visto
esordisse è stato jobs che proprio
questo po po impaurito pensa che solo a
chi è impegnato per togliere però avremo
notorieta la taberna sono usciti un
allentato torneo roger ha detto vabbè
lasciamo perdere il suo torneo i famigli
giovani in pericolo questa prima partita
passata proprio easy ok contro un team
italiano in torneo let's go live fake
lauri bliss niente sbagliato ma no
c'entra ero in mezzo proprio lui niente
separata arrivo subito sei tu ma
malissimo resta prezzo questa cattivo
allora che cosa successe rima stata otto
volte
vabbè
perché timone 0 in 2 bongiorno
buongiorno e arrivederci che ho visto
andare via va detto però non è più se
tutto va beh non parto bomba alla tua
mamma mia come arriva giusta
gigi vadino bomba non c'è in tutti i
trans ma come fai bene a trattarmi
proprio lui grande avrà più giusto
giusto tra gli altri mille di queste
fiducia però anche mille euro ma sono
molto tranquilla palla presta alla buona
mamma mia che cosa che sogno bevete dove
non tutti lo fanno trovare imparziale
bella addio santissimo bene così
ti aspetto a madonna imprendibile e
basta 6 a 1 regala un'altra volta 131
malato cataloghi fortissima infatti non
vista bella partita e bella potente di
favini g g proponendo di due dove entra
quello veramente forse bagnato no
ragazzi sicari al torneo ci cardiaci è
deciso di farci partire da grandissimo
ma quindi ma succede spesso sta roba non
ha mai capito già un paio di volte
mica che dispiacere beh dai a farebbe
sutri quindi si va bene lo so io ti fino
a quali sono forti io prendo foto
interessato per sa partito è
probabilmente sì lo so lo sento kick off
quindi si è questa partita
attenzione in mezzo lo calcolato non
entra la non entra non è entrato all new
trolls centro e milan e real madrid
no stilate medicina nero impegnatissimo
per si arrestò tiro non sono riusciti è
largo tutto ma proprio tutto ma poi
hanno fatto bene ho spinto mai
ma cosa fai ti odio ma dai non fare
anche il più lento ma lui di giusto o no
ragazzi mi dissocio la nostra partita
se io di aused ai a cosa infatti giuro
non costa niente non ho mai fatti non ho
visto che credo di aver visto male io vi
giuro che non me ne sono la nuova
feature l'avversario può prendere
controlli la macchina il tuo compagno
presenti poi esatta niente ci sta ci sta
tutto giusto avere tutto calcolare anche
questo
mannaggia però non si unito il terzo
tensione
eccolo ma che cosa strano tardi perché
allora sarai che glielo con salta così
la dentista per numerato sono in duelli
ciò di noi bella
ma chi dirà tu quindi era tutto ok vista
c'è questo strano che non ti abbiano
controllato per chi sbaglia va bene va
bene va bene se vedi visto avvicinando
il re presiedevo attivo la macchina è
così
sì sì sì ma non fa niente tanto lo
sappiamo lo sappiamo che ci avresti
provato ad ostacolare ma fa niente
comunque bella partita mi è piaciuta
ho bisogno di buste e si parte
cosa che all'inizio avevo bisogno di
propulsione si è questo il momento in
cui ho cambiato obiettivo miss inglese
perfetto va bene ragazzi non ho visto
cosa è successo ma mi sono fidato di
volta ho mai ci abbiamo creduto
[Musica]
vabbè che dolore alla parte rimasta lì
ho insegnato loro ho segnato io grado si
è grande non so come sia possibile a
perché calcolato calcolato i farini
arrivano cosa zero anche quasi quindi
finale sono ancora al centro per te
sapete in faccia più giusto e rossi ma
aveva di quadri un bacino più dove senza
ma no stanno volando tutti strano
ha presentato a pezzi ma la nato turbo
praticamente che sei inserimenti non ho
sentito la gara con registratore signor
lo riguarda ha detto bergognone piano
non tagliare non ho provato io vado non
solo quello che fa più punti della
partita però pesa una semina altri sta
nella bella e tiro di qashqai ce l'ha
non c'è ma al centro ma ma 11 totali
proprio niente è un assedio nora toccata
lo zio 20 pad in primari mela e vabbè
vabbè bisogno
attenzione però tu tutto calcolato tutto
il pechino passaggio tiene vedono turbo
però faccio una premessa non toccarla
vogliono guardare libri che uscì io sì
sì l'ho vista era proprio fuori stavolta
forse toccavano sai veramente non
entravo tranquillo e fame lo credere in
tornei
abbiamo vinto il torneo non sono
sorpreso per niente quando volete
vicevera cento in due in più di 22 reti
favini campioni favini cook è bella mi
piace sono trendy ragazzi anche oggi ci
portiamo a casa al nostro torneo per
primo che il primo gol e giocate da te
non ho mai fatto tornei se non appunto
con voi durante le live tra l'altro
seguite anche le live perché capiterà
che faremo torna insieme niente come
sempre ragazzi lasciato un commento mi
piace iscrivetevi al canale e noi come
sempre ci vediamo ad un prossimo video è
la ragazzi
[Musica]